انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض وانا صهيب شرايير وهذه
اخبار الساعه
كيف الغارقه في الظلام تستعد للشتاء قاسم
او النزوح وخيرسون تتاهبوا لمعركه وشيكا
بتحشيد اوكراني وروسيا مضاف
رصاص وقمع واعتقال النظام الايراني
يواصلوا حملته ضد المحتاجين والبرلمانيون
يطالبون القضاء باعدامهم
على اجنده قمه المناخ وعود بحاجه لتنفيذ
وخسائر تنتظر التعويض وارضا تتعطش لتتحرك
عاجل للانقاب
قبل يومين من الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا رسائل وتهديد للعاملين في مراكز
الاقتراع وتحذير من اعمال عنف
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
بصمت وحذر تستعد خيرسون للمعركه المنتظره
تحركه اللافته تشهدها المدينه الظلام بعد
انقطاع الكهرباء بالكامل عنها في العتمه
تتسارع الاستعدادات العسكريه وان بصعوبه
روسيا تعيد التفكير في استراتيجيه الهجوم
واوكرانيا اكتشفت سر تقدمها ميدانيا لكنها
تكافح في ظل تعرض بوناها التحتيه للطاقه
لان انهيار جراء القصر الروسيه وهذه
الاستراتيجيه اخرى اتبعتها موسكو لاجبار
القوات الاوكرانيه على التراجع او ربما
كسب مزيد من الوقت لتحضير معركه
[موسيقى]
اذا اخرسي تستعد لام المعارك او هكذا يبدو
على الاقل حسب المعطيات الوارده من هناك
المعركه بالنسبه للمعسكرين مفتاح السر في
صراع الجنوب استعدادات القوات الاوكرانيه
للهجوم على اخر سنه سلطات الاقليم الماليه
تلك الاتهامات مشيرا الى ان القوه الروسيه
تقوم باجلاء السكان العربي
ومن بين المؤشرات على قرب المعركه انقطاع
الكهرباء عن المدينه باكملها حيث افادت
وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عن شركه للطاقه في
المدينه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا عدم وجود
كهرباء في خيرسون باكملها
كما ان التقارير الاعلاميه تنبات كذلك
بمعركه خرسون ومن بينها صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز التي قالت نقلنا عن المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان روسيا نشرت نحو
اربعين الف جنديا على الضفه الغربيه للنهر
الدنفر لمنع الجيش الاوكراني من التقدم
كما افادت بوجود تحرك للمدفعيه الروسيه
الثقيله الى الضفه الشرقيه لنهر الدنفر
جنوب المدينه ودمرت القوه الاوكرانيه
الجسور التي تربط هيرسون بالاراضي التي
تسيطر عليها روسيا عبر دينيفر الى الشرق
مما يجعل من الصعب على موسكو تعزيز قواتها
في المدينه واعادته تموينيها
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نتوقف قليلا مع هذه الصور
المباشره تاتينا من العراق الان حيث انهار
مبنى تجاري بشكل جزئي بعد نشوب حريق في
منطقه الوزيريه في العاصمه بغداد وقال
مصدر طبي ان 10 من الدفاع المدني بينهم
مدير الدفاع المدني كاظم بوهان اصيبوا
جراء هذا الحادث ثمنه قد هي مستمره اخذ
مراسل العربيه بان فرق الدفاع المدني
تكافح الحريق منذ عشر ساعات ولا تزال
وتواصل البحث عن المفقودين في المملكه
التجاري واشارت كذلك الى ان سبب بسبب
اتساعه بسبب اتساعه هو امتداده الى مخازن
للعطور صور مباشره من الوزيريه في بغداد
[موسيقى]
نعود الى اوكرانيا وتحدثنا فيها من خرسه
اذا الغارقه في الظلام الى كيا في الان
التي تقف على اعتاب ظلام وشتاء قاسم
فالعاصمه التي بقي فيها ثلاثه ملايين نسمه
قد تشهدوا في ايه لحظه انقطاع عن كليا
لتيار الكهربائي وبالتالي لن يكون هناك
ماء او صرف صحي المدينه
التي تستهدف البنيه التحتيه للطاقه فعلى
الاوكرانيين الاستعداد للسيناريو اسوء هذا
الشتاء السلطات وضعت خطوطنا لاخلاء كيف من
سكانها اذا تلقى انذارا بانهيار شبكه
الكهرباء وتوقف الخدمات كما تجهز المدينه
الفالجا للتدفئه يمكنها ايضا حمايه
المدنيين من الصواريخ الروسيه ومعظمها
داخل مشات تعليميه لم تحدد مواقع مواقع
تمشي صوت
هذا لكن لنكون صديقيين اعدائنا يبذلون
قصار جهدهم لكي تكون المدينه من دون تدفئه
وكهرباء وامدادات المياه وبشكل عام يريدون
منا جميعا ان نموت هذه هي مهمتهم يعتمد
هذا على مدى قدرتنا على الصمود وعلى مدى
استعدادنا لسنر يوهات مختلفه يعتمد مستقبل
بلدنا ومستقبل كل مواطن على مستوى
الاستعداد لذا يجب ان نكون مستعدين
معنى من سنه بطرسبورغ الدكتور مسلم مشعته
رئيس المركز الثقفي الروسي العربي دكتور
اهلا بكم معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
هل تكون ام المعارك في الحرب الالكترونيه
والمشاهدين خلصن من المعارك المهمه جدا
لكنها لن تكون ام المعارك اما المعارك في
المستقبل ستكون مدن اخرى خير
الى ما قررت القوات الروسيه الاندفاع
الثانيه وخرصا هي الباب للوصول الى الكره
الى استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه بدعم فعلا
من الحلف نيته تخطي الضفه الى جهه الشرقيه
عفوا الى جهه الغربيه
حاليا بامتياز معركه النت وعلى ابواب
الانتخابات التي ستحصل في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
وكانه حجز امريكي لان تتم هذه المعركه
وتنجز قبل يوم الثلاثاء ولذلك نرى حشودا
استثنائيه من القوات الاوكرانيه تجاوزت
60,000 مقاتل مقابل حتى الان في خرسانه لا
دكتور نعلم ان خلص يعني هي من اولى
المناطق التي سيطرت عليها روسيا في
اوكرانيا واذا فقدتها يعني فاستكون يعني
هزيمه مدله بالنسبه لروسيا كما يقول
المتابعون لهذا السبب يعني روسيا تحشد
بقوه وهي يعني مصره على السيطره على كل
خير ام لاسباب اخرى
روسيا لا تتمسك بخرسانه وروسيا قال قائد
القوات العمليه العسكريه في منطقه
اوكرانيا اننا سنتخذ اجراءات صعبه وهذه
الاجراءات الصعبه هي احد احتمالاتها
والاكبر والانسحاب من خرسان لتقليل
الخسائر البشريه والبنيه التحتيه والخسائر
البشريه هنا في الطرفين العسكريه
الاوكرانيه والروسيه لان الروسيه تعتبر ان
هذه المدينه الروسيه وتدميرها وخسائر
بشريه من الطرفين هو خسائر لروسيا اذا
بالتالي روسيا لا تعتبرها مدينه اي شيء
بالدفاع عنها
وكانها نهايه المعارك هي احدى المعارك
التي يبدو ان الناتو يسعى جاهدا الى
الحصول على اي تقدم وهو يرغب اكيد بالحصول
على كل المدينه لكن هل هذا سيصبح حتى الان
ليس معروفا ولكن يعني هناك تلميحات دكتور
على انه خرسه انه ربما همم تكون ام
المعارك بالنظر الى التي بدات تعطى
لاوكرانيا من قبل اميريكا انه يعني على
اوكرانيا ان تكون منفتحه على الجلوس الى
طاوله الحوار مع الروس ربما لانهاء هذه
الحرب فهل برايك يعني هناك جديه برايك
لانه لانهاء هذه الحرب عبر التفاوض قريبا
نعم احسنت هذا السؤال قد يكون نوع من
موازين قوه تحصل بها اوكرانيا على خرسون
للدخول من مفاوضات من موقع القوه لكن هذا
سيكلفها كثيرا قد ينهي الجيش الاوكراني
وبالتالي يعيد المعركه باتجاه الدفاع
روسيه تزيل كل المناطق التي احتلتها
اوكرانيا اوجد احرى ما زالت تحت السيطره
الاوكرانيه هذه الخسائر التي
ستتبداها لا تستطيع القياده تحملها وروسيا
لن تجازف بالدفاع المستميت عن هذه المدينه
نعم سيصورون وكانه انجاز تاريخي في خرسون
همم يدفعون من خلاله الى مفاوضات مع روسيا
بشروط الامريكيه هذا لن يحصل وروسيا لم
تقبل والمعركه ما زالت لم تبدا كما قال
الرئيس بوتين انما حتى الان هي عمليه
محدوده محدده في مناطق معينه لا يمكن
الدفاع استماته عن اي منطقه عسكريه او
مدنيه لان الحرب لم تبدا حتى الان شكرا
جزيلا همم من سنه بيترسبورج دكتور مسلم
شعيته رئيس المركز الثقافي الروسي العربي
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا نعود الى العراق وهذه الصور
المباشره هناك من الوزيريه في بغداد يبدو
ان الدفاع المدني العراقي نجح في اخماد
هذا الحريق بالمبنى التجاري في بغداد بعد
فقدان اكثر من 10 اشخاص
بداخله كما نتابع واثار الحريق باديه على
الاقل يعني في جزء كبير من هذا المجمع ما
تزال بعض النيران همم مندلعه ولكن على ما
يبدو رجال الاطفاء نجحوا في السيطره على
الحريق الاكبر وكما نرى هناك سياره يعني
همم
تفحمت بعد اندلاع هذا الحريق اذا في هذا
المجمع اذا الدفاع المدني العراقي اعلن
انه اخمد الحريق الذي اندلع في مبنى
التجريبي وسط العاصمه بغداد في حين نقلت
وسائل الاعلام عن وزير الداخليه القوي
كذلك هنا اكثر من 10 اشخاص اذا ما زالوا
في عداد المفقودين داخل المبلغ اذا هذا
حدث متفاعل في العراق سنبقي انا عليه هو
نتابع معكم تطوراته اولا باكل
[موسيقى]
شدينا سنذهب الى فاصل بعد قليل في اخبار
الساعه نتابع تقريرا اماميا يحذر من فوضى
مناخيه تدمر البشر في كل القارات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في ايران وصلوا النظام
ونهج التصعيد ضد المحتاجين وبكل الوسائل
قتل اعتقالات ومحاكمات لا تقل عقوبتها عن
الاعدام وهذا ما طلب به 227 برلمانيه
المحتاجين بالمجرمين وطالبوا القضاء
باعدامه وذلك بعدما هاجم المحتاجون في
ايران مكتبه احد البرلمانيين واعلن
برلمانيون اخرون عن تعرضهم للضرب من قبل
المتظاهرين
وفي احتجاجاته اليوم المستمره في انحاء
ايران شهدت مدينه ماريواه النبي محافظه
كردستان ايران اطلاقا نار كثيف من قبل
قوات الامن على المتظاهرين وتاتي هذه
الاحتجاجات بعد دفن جثمان نسرين قادري فجر
اليوم في مدينه ماريان دون مشيعين بضغط من
الاجهزه الامنيه موقع ايران انترناشونال
افاده بان قادري كانت دخلت في غيبوبه قبل
يومين في طهران بسبب ضربات متعدده
بالهراوات من قبل القوات الامنيه توفي على
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
فار فار
الحرس الثوري الايراني ثلاثه خلايا تابعه
لجماعه المجاهدين خلق الايرانيه المعارضه
قناه العالم الايرانيه ذكرت الخبر مضيفه
ان الخلايا كانت تعتزم القيامه باعمال
وفارس من خلال تجنيد مدير الشغل في
الاحتجاجات ومهاجمه مراكز حكوميه وتدمير
الممتلكات ومحاوله قتل المواطنين حسب قناه
العالم دائما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنى من لندن البحث في الشان الايرانيه
عارف النصر والاستاذ عارف اهلا بكم معنا
ما اسباب استمرار هذه الحركه المناهضه
للنظام في ايران التي بدات قبل نحو شهرين
وكذلك اتساع رقعتها الجغرافيه الى كل
المناطق تقريبا في ايران
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ صهيب والمشاهده
العربيه الكرام الواقع يعني اذا ما اردنا
ان ان يعني نبحث عن اسباب هذه المظاهرات
ممكن الغول بان
الانسداد السياسي هو اهم الاسباب التي
ممكن ان ربما نركز عليها بمعنى ان لل
السلطه القضائيه وكذلك لا السلطه
التنفيذيه ولا حتى المرشد الايراني وحتى
وحتى الحرس الثوري كلهم لا يريدون التعامل
مع مع مطالب المحتجين واليوم دخل البرلمان
ايضا وهو ربما اخر الغناء التي ممكن كان
يتشبث بها البعض وحتى الصحافه الايرانيه
اليوم كانت
دخول البرلمانيين على الخط استاذ عارف
يعني ياتي ضمن يعني الروايه التي النظام
يحاول ان يضع في سياقها هذه الاحتجاجات
انها هؤلاء مجرمين وانه هؤلاء ربما مغرر
بهم من قبل امريكا واسرائيل ولكن يبدو
يعني هذا التصنيف او هذه الرؤيه هي تزيد
من غضب المحتجين بالعكس يعني لم تؤثر على
دائره المظاهرات
الفعل واضافته الى ذلك نحن لا ننسى بان
الماده 59 من الدستور الايراني تتيح في
حال ان الثلثي اعضاء البرلمان همم وقعوا
على على مذكره لاجراء استفتاء في ما يتعلق
ببعض المواد الدستوريه ممكن ان ان يدخل
هذا الاستفتاح التنفيذ لذلك هذا العدد
الهائل من
290 كرسي في البرلمان الايراني 227 شخص
يوقع بمعنى ان حتى البرلمان خارج من تصنيف
اجراء تعديلات او الذهاب الى الاستفتاء
كما دعا لذلك المولى حميد امام اهل السنه
في بلوشستان حتى الصحافه الاصلاحيه وهذا
ان دل على شيء يدل بان كل الدروب ربما الى
الاصلاحات من داخل النظام انغلت وهذا ما
يعني بان الشارع يجب ان يستمر بحراكه ثوري
وليس له طريق لا يسقط هذا النظام نعم طيب
استاذ عارف هناك من المتابعين من يقول انه
الاحتجاجات الحاليه في ايران هي اكبر تحدي
للنظام الايراني منذ الثوره في عام 79 هل
هذه مبالغه
يعني اليوم همم
التوجيه العسكري يعني قائد التوجيه
العسكري للحرس الثوري هو من اعترف بهذا
الامر بمعنى لاول مره تدوم الاحتجاجات الى
52 يوم وبهذا الزخم وبهذه المشاركه
الشعبيه وبهذا الالتفاف الشعبي همم ربما
للداخل والخارج وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان
الان النظام الايراني امام همم ربما يعني
همم ربما خيارات محدوده جدا اما اني ان
يسقي همم الى هذه المطالب واما ان ربما
يتكرر سيناريوهات كثيره منها سيناريو همم
عام 1979 وهو ربما عندما قال محمد رضا شاه
بان متاخرا بان سمعت صوتكم وبعده بايام
خرج من من ايران
شكرا جزيلا لك عارف ناصر ان تبحث في شان
الايراني مباشره من لندن كنت معنا
[موسيقى]
ملفات كثيره ومخاطر اكثر على اجنده قمه
التغير المناخي كوب 27 التي انطلقت اليوم
في مدينه شرم الشيخ البدايه من وعود الدول
التي وضعت في قمم سابقه وضعت وعودا بحاجه
الان الى التنفيذ وفي اسرع وقت قدم يمكن
انقاذه وتمر اعماله القمه على الخسائر
والاضرار التي تكبدتها الدول المتاثره
بالتغير المناخي فواتير باهظه تحتاج
للتمويل والتعويض خصوصا للفقراء الاكثر
تضرنا من كوارث الطبيعه ولا ينتهي الامر
بادراك المشترك على مستوى العالم
لمواجهه اكبر خطر يهدد البشريه وكوكبنا
كوكب الارض الذي يتطلب منه انقاذ
قمه المناخ هو المكان المناسبه لاعاده
بناء الثقه واعاده تاسيس الطموح اللازم
لتجنب كوكبنا كارثه مناخيه في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه تلقينا تقريرا تلو الاخر
يوضح الصوره القاتمه لا تزال الانبعاثات
تتزايد عند مستويات قياسيه بدلا من
الانخفاض بنسبه 45% بحلول عام 2030
انبعاثات غازات الاحتباس الحراري في طريقه
الان للارتفاع بنسبه 10% وفي الوقت نفسه
فان درجات الحراره في طريقها للارتفاع بما
يصل الى دراجتين فاصله ثمانيه مع اتباع
السياسات الحاليه بحلول نهايه القرن سيبقى
المناخ الى الابد في ارتفاع كارثي بدرجات
الحراره
[موسيقى]
لا شك ان التغييرات المناخيه باتت بشكل
وتحديدا حقيقيا للبشر على كوكب الارض
والتصدي لها اصبح حتميه والا فستقع
الكارثه المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
دقه ناقوس الخطر وحضرت بشكل صريح من ان
التغيير المناخي باتيسير بسرعه تاريخيه
تدمر البشره وسبل العيش في كل القاره
سنويا تزامنا مع قيمه شرم الشيخ وصفت فيها
وضع المناخ العالمي بالفوضى المناخيه
تقرير المنظمه الذي يعتمد على من تقدمه
الدول من بيانات بشان المناخ افاد بان
معدلات الحراره عالميا تشتد وشهدت ارتفاعا
عن ما كانت عليه بين عامين 1850 و1900
بمقدار درجه ونصف الدرجه مئويه كما ظهرت
تقرير عن ارتفاع مستوى البحر زاد بمعادل
الضعف عن ما كان عليه في عام 1993
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر معنا مباشره من شرم الشيخ
المدير التنفيذيه لجريم في
جرين بيتش عفوا الشرق الاوسط و شمال
افريقيا غوى النكت مرحبا بك معنا غوى في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه
الكوكب يزداد حراره ما مدى سوء الوضع
مرحبا فيك شكرا على استضافتك بالفعل الوضع
اخر تقرير لاله اللي اطلقني
قمه المناخ نحنا على شفير الهيويه عالميا
وبالاخص بمنطقتنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا مثل ما ازهر تقريبا وكل
الدراسات اللي حضرتك تفضلته وذكرتو هلا
الوضع كارثي
بزياده بنسبه الحراره عم ترتفع نحن مش
هنقدر نلتزم همم الدرجه ونصف اللي تعهدوا
فيها صناع القرار اذا من دل ماشيين
بالوثيره
بعدم الالتزام بالوعود
عم نشهد ارتفاع بدجاجات الحراره
كرسي عم تعرض المنطقه اسمه من المنطقه
يكون غير قابل للسكن للاسف كمان عم بنشهد
منطقتنا جفاف كثير حد عم باثر على سبل
العيش
وبالاخص الزراعه وعم بتاثر قلي السمكه
بالجفاف الي نحن عملنا عم نعيشه واكيد
زياده الحراره
مهم جيد للحفاظ على البيئه الان في قمه
شرم الشيخ حديث على انه سيكون هناك دول
فقيره ستحصل على التعويضات لانه الدول
الغنيه هي التي تسبب ارتفاع الحراره بسبب
تطور الصناعه فيها هي المتسببه في هذا
الاحترار برايك هل سيدفعون ومن سيدفع من
الدول المتقدمه
وم الدول التي ستحصل على هذه التعويضات
نحن حاليا مضبوط هذا همم سلب همم
مطالب بقمه همم 27 هو العديل للمناخي هو
انه الدول اللي تاريخيا دول الشمال
الصناعي اللي هي سبب من اكثر
همم الغازات الدافئه اللي وصلتنا لازمه
كارثه المناخ اللي نحن فيه همم تتحمل
المسؤولياته وتدفع تعويضات لا دول النيميه
واللي هي اكثر عرضه همم
لتغير المناخ التعويضات مسميه لتعويد
الخسائر والاضرار الناجمه عن تغير المناخ
وازمات المناخيه او هي دول الجنوب اكثريه
الدول الجنوب
للاسفهاميه بازمه المناخ ولكن
تعيش كل همم
تبعيتها الازمه من مثل ما قلنا يعني عن
همم الناس عم تفقد حياتها عم تفقد منازلها
مثل ما شفنا بفضانك باكستان ونيجيريا
مؤخره
والفلبين احدث بعد كمين المجفف اللي عم
بيوصل المجاعه
بالقرن الافريقي همم جفيف في الكمين اللي
بالقهوار العراق بمنطقتنا اللي همم عم
بيعانوا منه الناس وعم باثر
هذا طبيعي انه في همم ولكن غوى الحديث على
انه هذا التعويضات ربما تجاوز ال 500
مليار دولار الامر الذي يجعل البعض يشكك
انه كيف ستدفع هذه الدول المتقدمه او هذه
الدول الغنيه هل هي عن لديها استعداد
لتدفع هذا المبلغ
هلا هي اكيد هتحاول انه تتهرب منها
الموضوع ولكن في مسؤوليه تاريخيه
وابو اليوم نحنا بموضوع الاجنده انه ينطرح
على اجنده المؤتمر المنيخ هو انجاز انه
ينطح موضوع
التمويل للخسائر والادرار ولكن المهم انه
دول الجنوب الاكثر تضررا والجمعيات
الاهليه دل تضغط ليسير هذا القرار
في اخر المؤتمر بالتموين اكيد هنحاولوا
يتهربوا بس اذا بتسالني عن موارد التمويل
هي موارد كثير كبيره وان احنا شفنا ازمه
الكوفت كيف تموين همم
حاليا احنا بس بحب يعني شركات النفط
عملت عملت
[موسيقى]
هذا الحديث المناخ والاحترام واا الظواهر
التي نشاهدها جميعا هناك خاصه على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي نظريه مؤامره هناك من
يقول انه همم هذه التغيرات المناخيه كلها
مؤامره كيف ترد على هذا الكلام
يعني انا
بعتقد تقرير انه بيرد انه هذه مش مؤامره
تقرير ان احنا اطلع اني خصوصا لما منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا اوروبا
[موسيقى]
يوم اني فقط
يفصلانا عن اكثر المعارك شراسه في
الانتخابات انها الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه التي تشهد منافسه كبيره بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين لكن لن ندخل في
اجواء الانتخابات قليلا حيث يدور قلقوا
الان في بعض الولايات من اعمالي عنف خلال
هذا السباق في ولايه اريزونا مثلا ذكرت
وكاله رويترز ان العاملين في مراكز
الاقتراع المبكر يواجهون التهديدات عنيفه
تتضمن ارسال التهديدات عبر البريد
الالكتروني ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تتعلق بنشر المعلومات الشخصيه عبر
الانترنت وبحسب رويترز تم الابلاغ عن 140
تهديدا من خلال شهر واحد فقط لموظفي مكتب
الانتخابات وكذب فيها عباره سيتم اعدامكم
جميعا
[موسيقى]
وقبل الانتخابات احتضنت ولايتون سلفانيا
الرئيسيه وحدها ثلاثه رؤساء في خطوه من
الديمقراطين والجمهوريين على حد سواء الى
تعبئه ناخذه
مع اقتراب موعد انتخابات منتصف الولايه
يسارع الحسبان الديمقراطي والجمهوري على
حد سواء الى تعبئه ناخبيهم في بنسلفانيا
حيث المعركه الانتخابيه النصفيه المصيريه
حضنت ولايه بنسلفانيا الرئيسيه ثلاثه
رؤساء قبل عمليه اختراع حاسمه ستضع اسس
الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 20 24
اوباما مساندا الرئيس الحالي
يتمتع بقبضه قويه على الحزب الجمهوريه
وامام التجمع هاشد من الجمهوريين يستهزئ
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب على
قله عدد الناخبين في تجمع منافسه
الديمقراطيين لانتخابي بولايه بن سلمان
[موسيقى]
بدل امر وكانه حشد من 200 شخص
في المقابل نزل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الى الساحه والمفارقه هنا انه كان يتجنب
في ما سبق اعتلاء المنصات لجمع تبرعات
لحزبه معتبرا ان انتخابات منتصف الولايه
ستكون لحظه فريقه في مصير الديمقراطيه
داخل الولايات المتحده
ومع مساعي الحزب الجمهوري للسيطره على
الكونجرس حذر الرئيس الامريكي السابق
باراك اوباما من ان سيطره الجمهوريين على
الكونجرس ستجعلهم ينتقمون من منافسهم
السياسيين في اشاره منه الى انهم قد
يعزلون الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
[موسيقى]
ومن المقرر ان تحدد انتخابات التجديد
النصفي الحزب الذي سوف يسيطر على الكونغرس
فهل ستكون من نصيب الحزب الديمقراطي الذي
يسعى جاهدا للاحتفاظ بالغالبيه الضئيله
التي يتمتع بها في الكونغرس ام من نصيب
الحزب الجمهوري الذي يحاول اعاده قبضته
على مجلس الشيوخ والنواب سلطان العربيه
في اهلا بك معنا ما التحدي بالنسبه
الديمقراطيين في الامطار الاخيره قبل
الانتخابات النصفيه
تحدي الكبير بالنسبه
ان يستطيعوا اخراج الناخبين الديمقراطيين
يوم الانتخابات والتاكد من انهم ادلوا
باصواتهم ليس هناك حماس كبير في صفوف
المؤيدين للحزب الديمقراطي لذلك نحن
شاهدنا الرئيس السابق اوباما وقد جاء الى
فيلادلفيا وكان قبل ذلك في عده ولايات
امريكيه وهو يريد ان يدفع خصوصا بالافارقه
الامريكيين للذهاب الى التصويت والتاكد من
انهم يصوتون الديمقراطيين لماذا الناخبون
الديمقراطيون ليسوا متحمسين للذهاب
والخروج
باصواتهم هل من ضمن هذا التهديدات او
المخاوف الامنيه التي بدا الحديث عنها ام
لا
لا اعتقد ذلك ليس هناك حماس لديمقراطيين
لانهم لا يشعرون بشكل عام ان هناك معركه
كبرى بالنسبه لهم المستقلون ايضا لا يبدون
حماسا كبيرا للذهاب الى اقلام الاقتراح
هناك حماس اعلى في صفوف الجمهوريين وهذا
ما عكسه ايضا كلام الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب كما سمعناها قبل قليل
هناك الكثير من المعلومات المتضاربه حول
اتجاهات الناخبين ولكن بدون شك ان زعامه
الحزب الديمقراطي تريد من الديمقراطيين ان
يذهبوا الى اقلام على الاقتراع وان يصوتوا
وهذا هو التحدي الاكبر بالنسبه
للعاده الحزب الموجود في البيت الابيض لا
يحقق انتصارا غالبا يعني في الانتخابات
النصفيه في الكونغرس لماذا كل يعني هذه
الحمراء همم راينا يعني رموز من الحزب
الديمقراطيته ساند بايضا بكثافه وفي
الولايات متارجحه كذلك من اجل حث الناخبين
على التصويت لماذا كل هذا الدعم وهذا
الاصرار
من السهل
ولبب نستطيع القول من الاسهل على الرئيس
الامريكي ان يتعاطى مع كونجرس من حزبه
لانهم في اجنده سياسيه واحده على الصعيد
الداخلي وعلى الصعيد الخارجي عندما يكون
الكونجرس مخالف حزبيا للرئيس الحالي يصبح
على الرئيس ان يبذل المجهود الكبير لاقناع
اعضاء الكونجرس بالتصويت على اي قانون
يريده الرئيس
سنشهده خلال سنتين المقبلتين لو انتصر
الجمهوريون في احدى غرف الكونجرس هو من
مفاوضات طويله وعذاب بالنسبه للرئيس ايضا
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه قرارات الى
الماسك تقصر اجنحه العصفور الازرق اراد
تويتر في خط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
تويتر
بدات تتاثر بقرارات الملك الجديد والدليل
عدد من الشركه الكبرى اعلاناتها مؤقتا على
تويتر
هذه الشركات تتخوف من التغيرات المحتمله
في سياسات تويتر حيث قالت شركه فولز فاجن
مثلا انها تراقب الوضع عن كثب وستقرروا
مسار الخطوه المواليه بناء على التطورات
ونقلت شبكه قيام حوالي 20 عميلا بتعليق
الانفاق الاعلاني على تويتر مشيره الى
انزعاج العديد من المديرين التنفيذيين
لهذه الشركات من المغادره المفاجاه اما
بسبب الاستقاله او الاقاله لكبار
المسؤولين التنفيذيين في اقسام التسويق
والمبيعات الاعلانيه على تويتر الاكثر من
ذلك هو ان شركات الاعلان نفسها بدات تتخذ
موقفا سلبيا من التعامل مع تويتر حيث ذكرت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز هذا الاسبوع
احدى اكبر شركه للاعلان في العالم اصدرت
توصيه للعملاء بايقاف الانفاقهم مؤقتا
حالات
[موسيقى]
هنا وزير الدفاع السعوديه خالد بن سلمان
نظيره العراقي ثابت العباسي بمناسبه
تعيينه في منصبه الجديد
التهنئه على صفحتها على تويتر مثيره الى
انه تعرض في اتصال هاتفيه مع نظيره
العراقيه العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
كما تبحثا تطوير التعاون والتنسيق في مجال
الدفاع
[موسيقى]
استبعد رئيس الوزراء اليمني معين عبد
الملك تحقيق السلام بسبب اسرار ايران على
سلوكها العدواني والابتزازي عبر ادواتها
المتمثله في جماعه الحوت
المعركه ضد الحوثيين بانها مصري
[موسيقى]
في السودان جدد رئيسه مجلس السياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان في كلمه الله
بقاعده حطاب العسكريه الشماليه الخرطوم
اي جهه سياسيه وحد المؤتمر الوطني على
الانسحاب من المشهد السياسي
الوطني
عند الناس
السودانيه فرصه خلوا الناس يشوفوا في
البلد ما تحسبوا لانه الجيش يرجع لكم ثاني
معكم ده كلام مولع اي زوال
ما عندها قيمه ولا عندها معنا
[موسيقى]
في تونس تلقت الدوائر الابتدائيه بالمحكمه
الاداريه 60 طعنا تتعلق بالترشيحات
للانتخابات التشريعيه المقرره في السابعه
عشره من ديسمبر المقبل حسب ما افادت وسائل
الاعلام التونسيه وهكذا مصدر بالمحكمه ان
الدوائر الفضائيه الابتدائيه بدات في عقد
جلسات المرافعه بالنسبه للطحون المقدمه
على ان يجري التصريح بالحكم فيها خلال
الايام الثلاثه المقبله
[موسيقى]
ايطاليا يبدو ان حكومه جورج جميل
على قوارب المهاجرين التي ترثوا على سواحل
البلاد بين ضفه هربوا منها وضفه اوروبا
التي يحلمون بها فقد منعت سلطات الايطاليه
يوم مركبه سفينه انقاذ في سواحل صقليه من
دخول الاراضي الايطاليه وسامحت فقط بنزول
القاصرين والمرضى وطلب وزير الداخليه
الايطالي سفينه الانقاذ بمغادره المياه
الاقليميه الايطاليه وعلامتها العشرات مما
لم يسمح لهم بالنزول اتي هذا في وقت نشد
فيه ثلاث صفوف انقاذ اخرى تقل نحو التاسعه
مئه مهاجر راسيه في عرض البحر نشدت
بالسماح لها بان ترسم
لكن لم يستجب لطلبه
احتجت منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه على اليتي
الاختيار تلك باعتبارها غير قانونيه وغير
انساني عضو البرلمان الايطاليه المنتمي
للمعارضه ابو بكر الصماهورو والذي كان
حاضرا لدى نزول المهاجرين ندد بما وصفه
التمييز والاختيار بين مهاجرين غرقت
زوارقهم وقطعوا رحله المحذوفه بالمخاطر في
الوصول الى اوروبا وقالت في تغريده على
تويتر سيتم الطعام بهذا القرار لدى الهيئه
المختصه اذا تم رفضه الناجين المتبقيين
[موسيقى]
هذه الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرز
اخبارها
كيف الغارقه في الظلام تستعد للشتاء قاس
او النزوح وخرفن تتاهب لمعركه وشيكا
بتحشيد اوكرانيا وروسي مضاف
رصاص وقمع في اعتقال نظام الايراني واصل
حملته ضد المحتجين والبرلمانيون يطالبون
القضاء باعدامهم
على اجنده قمه المناخ وعود بحاجه للتنفيذ
وخصائر تنتظر التعويض وارضا تتعطش لتحرك
عاجل لانقاذها
قبل يومين من الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا رسائل وتهديد للعاملين في مراكز
الاقتراع وتحذير من اعمالنا
شكرا لكم على كلام المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى العربيه على صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]